[Music]
that in quite a few terrific films in
the last couple of years yes that should
not have happened by the way I should
not be in any movies at all right but I
was in very briefly and there will be
blood yes I remember I remember you in
front there will be blood my co-star
Daniel day-lewis if he's watching d-day
hello that's what we called I don't know
if you're acting smug or if you just had
a stroke yeah I was it with the sandbag
guys have any rivals in the theater yeah
I was in the movie I was in the movie
Magnolia another Paul Thomas Anderson
joint and I was in the movie The
Informant with Matt Damon I did not see
that movie this is I I'm sorry a lot of
people missed that one it's worth seeing
and it's got an exclamation point at the
end of the title so I feel like there's
an urgency to you seeing it right well
okay so you got to shoot scenes with
Matt Damon I got to shoot scene with
Matt Damon a very brief exchange with
mr. Damon
oscar-winner Matt Damon I sat across the
table from him for an afternoon and that
was my whole part and it was it was very
exciting to be in there on the set and
see this big movie being made see this
big movie being made that's how I think
of my part that film was like I won a
contest that I got
whenever you're in a movie you're
usually just never in character you can
see me suddenly mouthing I hope I get a
free hat but I sitting across from Matt
Damon and during a break in the filming
they're they're resetting the cameras
and everything and he's telling a story
and while he's telling his story he's
just very calmly chatting telling the
story an assistant comes over to him and
places in front of him this this clear
bowl with this very bright blue liquid
in it and then floating in this bright
blue liquid was a smaller bowl and in
the smaller bowl were these two sort of
opaque gelatinous cubes and so he's
telling this story and I'm looking at
this the cubes in the bowl and then as
he's telling the story just very calmly
doesn't miss a beat just takes the cubes
out of the bowl and puts them in his
mouth and everyone else around the table
is acting like this isn't crazy everyone
else did not notice no one else
acknowledges this and I'm sitting there
like what were those cubes
do they always cubes I think of the week
meet you I was freaking out about this
and I was too scared to ask anyone ask
Matt what's those cubes yeah
also where's the free hat yeah a year
goes by I am telling the story on stage
at the Vancouver comedy festival and I
get to the part about the cubes and how
I don't know what they are and I hear a
voice from the back of the room say I
know what those cubes are and I say who
said that and the voice says it's me Tom
or Colt well hey it's me Tom Arnold well
of course it what kept you Tom Arnold
yeah
so Tom Arnold is attending this festival
he stands up in the back and says I have
the answer that's right
so I said Tom Arnold what were those
cubes and he said was it towards the end
of filming and I said yes it was Tom
Arnold I distinctly remember this was
the final week of filming why and he
said he had gained weight to play the
role and he was sensitive filming was
winding down he was beginning the weight
loss process and those cubes are part of
a weight loss cleanse and I said Tom
Arnold you have done it meaning you have
cracked the case and Tom Arnold says
clearly I haven't done it
tomorrow that is not what I'm in we uh
[Applause]
do you know anything more about this
cleanse it's just those are cubes that
you eat you know what they're many know
what the blick would say why does it
need to float in blue liquid like here I
was thinking Oh Matt Damon is an
extraterrestrial yeah yeah he's those
cubes to breathe yeah breathing fuel a
celebrity could get a big a-list
celebrity can get away like any other
alien that came to earth would have to
hide that from everyone else so I must
go in the basement and check on matters
but an a-list celebrity can just right
in front of people but have tentacles
come out I'm good at your earth
pretending so I just need these cubes to
breathe your atmosphere and also one
diva move since I'm a star could you put
him in some blue liquid yeah